controversia en israel por el supuesto
uso ilegal del programa espía pegasus
según los últimos informes del periódico
cálculo list jefes de ministros
periodistas alcaldes activistas y
personas cercanas al ex primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu incluido uno de sus
hijos fueron blanco de espionaje las
revelaciones han influido en el juicio
por corrupción de netanyahu después que
el tribunal que lleva su caso
suspendiera el proceso la atención se ha
centrado de nuevo en la empresa israelí
ns o cuyo programa espía pegasus fue
usado como arma diplomática durante la
era de netanyahu irónicamente fue el
propio netanyahu en diciembre de 2015
quien animó al nuevo jefe de policía a
utilizar la tecnología de ciber
vigilancia creo que hará un gran trabajo
con la tecnología cibernética espero ron
y que utilices estas tecnologías para
hacer cumplir la ley pero también para
la protección diaria de los civiles la
unidad de ciber inteligencia de la
policía está acusada de instalar el
programa espía pegasus en los teléfonos
sin autorización
las revelaciones han dejado al gobierno
israelí en una situación incómoda el
primer ministro ha prometido una rápida
investigación
en relación con el asunto pegasus los
informes aparentemente describen una
situación muy grave que es inaceptable
en una democracia ver realmente nada
democrático clase de la l estas
herramientas cibernéticas fueron
diseñadas para luchar contra el
terrorismo y los delitos graves no para
ser utilizadas contra los ciudadanos
el programa espía pegasus ha estado en
el centro de un escándalo mundial que ha
durado varios meses tras descubrirse que
gobiernos de todo el mundo utilizaban
esta tecnología para espiar a rivales
políticos activistas periodistas e
incluso jefes de estado